[موسيقى]
انا نسمه المله ام ثلاثه اطفال
ومحاربه مع ابن البطل فارس ضد اللوكيميا
فكره التثقيف الصحي
للعامه بدات انه انا كان حسابي خاص
حساباتي كلها كانت خاصه انستقرام وسناب
شات بدات في سناب باصور في المستشفى كل
يوم اكتب يوميات فارس مع العلاج من بدايه
التشخيص فبداوا انا عارفه هو صاحباتي
يقولوا لي طيب
في ناس كثير ما يعرف المعلومات
[موسيقى]
اللي انت بتقولها انها حاجه احنا اول مره
نسمعها
فكرت في الموضوع وقتك كنت في الثانويه
[موسيقى]
فكره اللقاء بس كنت مشغوله في علاج فارس
فالحمد لله خلص علاجه الان وقدرت اتفرغ
الافكار اللي كانت في بالي من اول من
ضمنها فكره لقاء الامهات
والفكره منه انه مشاركه مجتمعيه عشان في
يعني يوفر الامهات ليه اجاذبه تحس نفسيتهم
[موسيقى]
تقدر
اليوم حيكون معانا في اللقاء كوتش تقدم
لنا جلسه يوجا وتعطينا نصائح للتعامل مع
الضغوطات اعتقد انه كل يوم محتاجه يعني
الامهات عموما وخصوصا وامهات ابطال
السردينه
همم انصح الامهات الجدد
امهات ابطال البكيني انهم او امهات
السرطان عموم يعني انها تحاول تحافظ على
هدوئها وقدام الطفل خصوصا لانه هو يستمد
قوته مني او من امه في كل ما يشوفك قويه
وصامدا يعرف ان الامور تحت السيطره فهو
يطمن فهي دي الفكره الاساسيه في دور الام
او الاهل عموما مع اطفالهم
[موسيقى]